His final game in the big leagues in a Mariner's uniform.
Able to write his own final chapter.
19 years in the Major Leagues.
A 353 career hitter over in Japan, over the last seven years,...
...Ichiro gets ready to make his Major League debut in a Mariner's uniform...
...wearing number 51 on his back.
258!
My, oh my!
One of the great moments in baseball history right here.
Career base hit number 2000.
Number 3000 in his professional career, the Seattle Mariners, Ichiro Suzuki.
Inside the park, home run, in an All-Star game.
He runs, he throws, he catches, he does it all.
Standing ovation for Ichiro Suzuki; he's back where it all began.
What a grab by Ichiro!
He's got the record!
More hits than any man in Japanese history.
Another Ichiro Mari-night  in Seattle.
And as far as the folks go in Cooperstown,...
...you can go ahead and start making that flag for number 51, Ichiro Suzuki.
Ichiro!